the deputy leader of the labour party
good morning
um
if we can get past yesterday's business
for the moment
did
uh kia stammer talk to you
about his proposed rule changes before
the conference
of course yeah and he spoke to the trade
unions and many others about the
proposals that he felt that we needed to
have a conversation about and that's
normal in in conference period we're
we're not happy unless we're talking
about a rule amendment a reference back
or a compensating meeting that's just
the normal hut and tussle of what we do
at conference so yeah you know he wanted
that consultation he wanted that
discussion we had our nec which passed
and approved um some proposals that are
going to go to conference floor and
that's how we do things in the labour
party so
another labour party tradition
the two of you clearly didn't disagree
because you put forward a separate
amendment to his proposal at the nec
well i'm not going to discuss what
happened at the private meeting of the
nec is the case but one of the things
that i'm concerned of and i always have
been and i've stood on the platform is
that we are able to diversify our
candidates and the way in which we you
know are able to you know choose people
as counselors as mayors as as leaders
and as myself as deputy leader you know
i wanted to make sure that for example
we're able to have more women on the
ballot and that we're able to have more
black asian and minority ethnic
candidates on the ballot so my concerns
around that is to make sure that we
don't inadvertently create a problem for
ourselves when we actually want to have
a broad base of candidates on that
ballot so that people can but if the two
of you were talking about it so amicably
that means he came into this conference
basically ignoring what you wanted and
the slogan for the party conference says
together
and the future
how are people expected to believe that
you and kirsten are together for the
future when you can't even apparently
agree on the present well we did agree
you know we all agree we are in
agreement that well why did you have
this why did you feel the need why did
you feel the need to amend
what he put forward to the nec it wasn't
it was a tidying up of what was the same
thing that we were both trying to
achieve so it wasn't a it wasn't we call
them friendly amendments in the movement
is where you actually are just trying to
tidy up the wording because sometimes
you want to put something in and that's
your aim but the unintended consequences
sometimes have you know the ability to
disenfranchise and that was what we were
doing you know that's what my um
concerns were is that we continue to
make sure that we have a broad diverse
group of candidates that come forward so
that people can vote for that all right
one more piece of conference business
chair of the conference margaret beckett
when she opened yesterday talked about
civility so did the general secretary
david evans uh when he made his speech
um
you said last night we cannot get any
worse than a bunch of scum homophobic
racist misogynist
absolute pile of banana republic itonian
piece of scum
um is that the kind of civility that the
stama rainer labour party envisages
well look that was post watershed as
we'd say and with a group of activists
at an event last night and and what i
was trying to get across
and this is the
and it is my passionate way in which i
do it is the anger
and frustration
that people feel when you have a prime
minister who has said things and not
apologizing that our racist that are
misogynistic that are homophobic that
has given billions of pounds of
taxpayers money to their mates and
literally wasted that money at a time
when they're cutting universal credit
plunging families into crisis and the
cost of living is going up then my
passion was about look we can't sit on
the sidelines here we have to get
organised and i was speaking to a group
of activists to say you've got to get
that fire in your belly the reason i was
so upset
about what the government did especially
on the school meals was because i was a
child that was hungry and i was a child
that needed that support and i remember
tory ministers at the time when i was 16
saying women like me girls like me at 16
were just getting pregnant to get
council houses so when the prime
minister uses language like calling
muslim women letter boxes that has an
effect and the fact that he hasn't
apologized for that then for me i don't
think he's fit to govern and i was
saying to a group of activists late at
night get your fire in your belly we
cannot sit on the sidelines anymore
we've got to get into power because
we've got to make things better for
ordinary working people in this country
look we can all get carried away but you
talked about a bunch of them you talked
about tories in general um
no
let me be clear i'm talking about
members of the cabinet so you've got the
home secretary who was bullied senior
civil servant okay reached the
ministerial code had private meetings
without civil servants okay president
and nothing's been done about that we've
have other cabinet members that have
said appalling things okay so i think
this government it's this government
we're being quite specific about who the
scum are would you want to give me a
list of names well i think anyone who
leaves children hungry during a pandemic
and can give billions of pounds to their
mates on whatsapp i think that was
pretty scummy now that is a phrase and
let me contextualize it it's a phrase
that you would hear very often in
northern working-class towns that we
would even say it jovially to other
people you know we say it's a scummy
thing to do and that to me is my street
language as you would say about actually
it's pretty appalling that people think
that's okay to do yeah look i'm not
going to get into an argument about you
you you pride yourself on being plain
speaking and that's all fine
but
would you like to take this opportunity
perhaps to apologize to the 14 000
people
in ashton underlying who voted
for a tory
and the tory scum that you
describe
by suggesting and now you're suggesting
that somehow
their choice
they made a choice
to be racist homophobic
and scummy let me be clear i am not
saying that anyone who voted for the
conservatives are racist scummy and
homophobic i'm saying the prime minister
do you just want to let's just steal it
why don't you apologize to the concert
those who voted conservative in ashland
on the line and by the way the millions
who voted conservative in those red wall
seats sure i'm satan and i'm very clear
i'm not saying anybody who voted
conservative are those things i'm saying
the prime minister
has said those things and has acted in
that way and if the prime minister wants
to apologize
and remove himself from those comments
that he's made that are homophobic that
are racist that are misogynistic come on
then i will apologize for calling
himself okay come on come on no i'm very
you could just deal with it you could
just deal with it very simply
honestly i'm really serious about this
because i i feel really passionate about
the fact that when you've got a prime
minister of the country that thinks it's
okay to use the language that he's used
then that is appalling that is called
you okay kirsten scum
you called i'm sorry is that is that
this ability that we're talking about
now because i've said that i'm very
clear that if the prime minister wants
to remove himself from those comments
i'm quite happy to apologize for calling
him scum all right if he wants to remove
himself from those comments the racist
misogynistic homophobic comments that
he's made very effective they're all
documented very offensive comments then
i will apologize to him personally for
calling himself if he wants to say that
he apologizes and doesn't mean the
comments that he's made in the past i'll
happily do that okay i'm sure he's
watching and he'll drop you a line let's
talk about policy um you plan to
legislate to compel employers and unions
to talk to each other um
what happens when the unions
and the employers disagree
well they go through the disputes
procedure there is a formal process for
them to do that you know it's well
documented but what this does actually
by having collective bargaining and
having that negotiation often they come
to agreement because employers and trade
unions have one common aim and that's
the business to flourish because without
the business you don't have the
membership and you don't have the
workers so what's new about this policy
employers and trade unions talk all the
time well what's new about this policy
of course in those sectors where we have
collective bargaining and i talk about
the social care sector and many social
care workers now do not have the
mechanism for fair pay agreements for
example and therefore i talk about how
that undercuts their wages 600 000 care
workers are not paid the minimum wage
they don't get you know i talked about
in my speech about how they don't get
travel time so i really want to increase
the standards in care so that people who
receive care get the best care but it's
great for business as well because staff
retention is a problem we know we've got
vacancies skills that we lose when you
have to skill people up again to do that
job actually works better when you pay
people better i get all that but you've
christened this the new deal for working
people um let me remind you 200 2017
labor manifesto said that labour would
repeal the trade union act roll out
sector collective bargaining raise a
minimum wage at least 10 pounds a 2019
labor manifesto said that you would roll
out sexual collective bargaining across
the country bringing workers and
employers together to agree legal
minimum standards on a wide range of
issues that every employer would have to
adopt what exactly is new about the new
deal for working people well trevor i'm
consistent if nothing else to be fair
and then on top of that there's a suite
of other things that we announced so
we've done a lot of detailed work on
this the green paper that i produced
yesterday published has things like you
know rights from day one for all workers
talking about a single status for
workers so that we have the parental
leave that we have
rights for unfair dismissal from day one
and that people can get that support i
talked about flexible working people
joined the pandemic have worked more
flexibly than ever before homework and
other ways of working and i think we
should roll that out out and have an
opportunity for people to have more
flexibility and employers will benefit
from that in terms of all the different
sectors that we have across the whole of
the economy yeah look you
you're essentially recycling a policy
okay you can call it new if you like
this morning
the leader has said that
he effectively wants to remove the tax
advantages that private schools
have
this sort of feels
uh a bit like warmed up corbinism of
2017 and 2019. what is different about
the kier stama angela rayner leadership
from what was offered in 2019 well some
of our values stay the same trevor
throughout that's the labour party
that's what we've always been we've
always been a party of social justice
and about tackling inequality inequality
in the uk has grown under the
conservatives what we're saying is that
it's about priorities we shouldn't be
subsidizing private education when
you've got so many young people now who
haven't got those opportunities that
what we're saying is that money should
go back into supporting young people who
need that support and it's about
priorities and it's about showing the
difference between what a conservative
government does like that on the issue
of the tax hike on the issue of
universal credit and what we would do
completely different and our values are
about tackling inequality not just
saying it but tackling it
let's let's deal with the issue the
difference between talking the talk and
walking the walk um
is it embarrassing
that of the four biggest parties in
parliament now the labour party is the
only one that's never had a woman leader
well i i did an interview recently at
the weekend and described um kiera as a
feminist and he is and you know
but he's not a woman as far as i know
he's not a woman no but you know it's
about how you bring people forward and
about people putting their names forward
i hope we'll have a female leader one
day i'm absolutely committed to that
supporting somebody going forward or
taking that issue forward but care has
been very strong on supporting women and
i can only say as his deputy that the
first conversation i had with him which
was a very serious one because if you
remember boris johnson was very poorly
at the time and i had covered and kir's
first conversation with me when we were
elected leader and deputy was angela if
i'd get covered if something happens to
me i need to put the mechanisms in place
for you to be able to take over that is
a sign of respect for my role and my
states in the organization
i think it's important that and it's an
important point here men
can be feminists and support women in
their career choices and support them
whether in the in the workplace as
yourself and others or actually by um
supporting them soft or hard in terms of
how they can bring them forward but
that's an important role for men as well
as when they're putting themselves let's
just deal with let's let's just deal
very quickly if you may and last
question
in supporting women
how can women in britain
trust labor to support women
when labor cannot even guarantee
the safety and gain the confidence of
its own woman mps
rosie duffield is not here because she
does not feel safe
yeah and that is a concern of mine that
rosie didn't feel safe to attend
conference but let me let me say
something about trev this trevor because
it's really serious and it crosses all
political parties what i have been
shocked by especially my female
colleagues and that's conservative
female mps as well is the level of
misogynistic abuse they get i've had
death threats many so many of them i
thought it was just because i've become
deputy leader the labour party that it
upped on a scale nothing but speaking to
colleagues across the house
level of abuse is disgusting and it has
to stop and you know
lindsey hoyle the speaker of the house
spoke about this as well he made it a
big key issue at his g7 meeting we need
to make sure that our politics means
that we can have the discourse that i
have with boris and others that's right
but abuse at that level is completely
unacceptable and rosie deserves our full
support and protection against that and
she would get that if she'd come to
conference we would have risk assessed
and made sure that she had every bit of
support that she needed to be here and
anybody who abuses rosie duffield who is
a member of the labour party would go
through our formal complaints procedure
and i'd expect a robust response on it
angela thank you very much indeed thank
you